quand quand tu es allé le voir il a eu
l'élégance de dire que ça faisait
plaisir de travailler avec toi non c'est
ce qui fait les grands metteurs en scène
enfin j'ai eu l'impression que enfin il
a été très chaleureux tout de suite
c'est le premier rôle que j'ai eu aussi
facilement a priori je suis arrivé dans
son bureau je vais rencontrer pour la
première fois je pensais que j'allais
devoir lire ou faire quelque chose et
gare au moment où jean louis lima il m'a
dit au roi jeudi mais mais quoi qu'il se
passe j'ai pas lire o connell ma finance
et vous tu le fais si tu as envie de le
faire c'est toi et j'étais vraiment très
surpris et évidemment je vous le dire
encore très honoré de travailler qu'un
metteur en scène qui m'a vraiment en
tout cas moi donné envie de faire du
cinéma
voilà bien sûr devenu un peu de nouveau
jean reno ya pire il ya faire nos tu
t'en sors bien est ce que tu as dit à
nicole kidman que tu faisais la voix
française de son ex non mais je les dis
à sydney quand j'ai rencontré parce
qu'en fait ayant doublé tom cruise dans
eyes wide shut
j'avais énormément de scènes avec sydney
pollack donc c'était étrange de le voir
et de le rencontrer j'avais l'impression
que j'avais déjà fait un film et je vous
dis pas ça par les cuves et avec elle un
peu coûts accrus
j'ai seulement internet extraordinaire
spielberg l'appel sur son portable
sydney pollack lui propose des rôles
c'est magique non c'est plutôt agréable
de travailler avec des metteurs en scène
wen qui font ray et puis et quand j'ai
vu l'interprète j'étais vraiment c'est
marrant ça fait je ne sais pas une
quinzaine d'années que je fais du cinéma
et quoi et quand j'ai vu les premiers
plans de ce film j'ai eu un sourire
comme si un rêve d'enfance concrétisait
quoi voilà parce que c'est vraiment le
cinéma c'est le cinéma mairie n'est
maman aime quoi c'était le cinéma voilà
c'est du cinéma